the big injuries coming out of the first
week of games chris let's start with
george kittle
knee sprain
status for sunday in doubt
thanks for nothing jimmy garoppolo with
the hospital ball on a screen pass when
i saw that yesterday hey i'm telling you
that that was a hor chris you were
talking about it sunday and i hadn't
seen it that was a horrible thrill what
the hell is garoppolo doing he's right
there i it's a screen pass and then
kiddo there's a certain point and i
respect
kittle's grit determination there's a
certain point where you just look up and
say see ya i'm not i'm not jumping up
trying to catch that damn thing yeah i
mean seriously jimmy garoppolo did not
throw the ball well on sunday there's no
other way to say it he didn't play that
well either all together so yeah there's
work to be done there and that's a huge
blow we know that i mean george kittle
is the best player on their offense and
then even more important right now
because we've discussed over the last
two weeks they're so banged up at the
end the wide receiver position
i'm sure shanahan had extra plays for
george kittle last week because of the
lack of receivers he probably had to say
i need to find maybe just a few more
ways to get george the ball now you're
going into week two not sure if he's
gonna play do all that he's great in the
run game he's great decoy i mean a lot
of what they do offensively is centered
around him so that will hurt this
football team who's kind of trying to
find their way offensively here
yeah i remember last year he had that
knee injury on a thursday night against
the car arizona right where it looked
horrible
it looked like he was done and he gutted
it out and played most of the game he
took some drives off not voluntarily i
mean his knee was at a point where he
couldn't go but then remember those
images of him in a suite and cheering i
mean the guy is he's just he's
everything football should be exactly
right but he did miss a couple of games
last year because of that
and who knows status in doubt for sunday
they don't have to tell us anything
until tomorrow and even then all they
have to tell us tomorrow is whether or
not he practiced and if so was he
limited and it'll be knee in parentheses
but uh we need to see what happens come
friday when a label is applied as to his
availability for sunday's game michael
thomas new orleans saints i had a
feeling this was coming chris based upon
the crickets that emanated from the new
orleans locker room after the game the
best i could get was they hadn't looked
at him yet they're trying to and he's
not letting them well what high level
athlete when he knows he's injured is
going to say sure take a look at it and
confirm for me what i'm fearing high
ankle sprain that's the bad kind of
ankle sprain that's the ankle sprain
that takes four to six weeks to heal he
believes he can play through it but i
would submit to you chris every year
there's 10 15 guys who suffer high ankle
sprains who believe they can play
through it yes until they realize that
they can't right they go out there and
maybe they're okay to kind of get it
done but somebody steps on that foot or
just barely hits that ankle and all of a
sudden you go whoa
it feels as bad as it did when i
sprained it and i barely you know
someone just barely touched it
so he's tough as hell we know just like
george kittle he's another guy where you
just go this is the kind of guy i want
in my locker room on my team leading my
wide receiving core he's going to give
everything he's got to go play but it's
going to affect him certainly at least
well like with michael thomas and such a
big part of his game is over the middle
quick passes things like that maybe he
can get away with it to a degree
nonetheless i think the saints would
love to have him out there a little like
when we talk with kiddo just to be a
decoy to help get other guys open
because i think you know the depth of
their receiving core
and just how talented they are is
something a little the question about
that team a little bit here going
forward
jordan reid looked pretty good uh on
sunday uh relatively speaking a guy that
yeah i thought was going to retire so
that helps it does it's not george
kittle and you're right get him out
there if you can if he's safe and
back to kittle kudos to him for taking
the stand and getting his contract this
is exactly why you do that right because
that season-ending injury that's going
to derail your opportunity to ever even
get that big contract is one play away
at any given time and you know marlon
mack the colts running back i feel
horrible for him contract year
supplanted for the future by jonathan
taylor you use a second round pick on a
running back you're not bringing him in
to be you know a gadget player or a
special teamer you have plans for this
guy or you don't use a second round pick
on him and then marlon mack first game
of his contract year torn achilles out
for the year taylor takes over as the
starter but uh chris i feel horrible
marlon mack because here's what's gonna
happen he's gonna end up signing a one
year yes two million dollar deal at the
most next year at the most
uh maybe something with incentives
minimum salary with incentives something
like that right all because of that one
play that one moment the first game of
the season it's uh a damn shame there's
no other way to say it i feel for the
kid
he's he's a really good football player
and you know for
for he's he's certainly
a t a running back that every team would
want whether you'd want him as your
number one or a great number two i think
that's what he is he's kind of like a
low level one but i would look at him
and go that's the perfect number two
compliment back he can do everything and
when you ac tear an achilles attendant
and you're a running back you're exactly
right
he's probably gonna get like you said
minimum with some incentives to see
where it goes and hopefully he can have
somewhat of a good year to build on it
to then maybe get another better
one-year deal after that it's just a
brutal part of that position and i do i
feel bad for marlon mack the colts
themselves should be okay because like
you said nahim heinz jonathan taylor
even the kid jordan wilkins they got
they got three pretty capable running
backs to carry the carry the load there
but uh it doesn't make me feel any
better about marlon mack i'm sorry about
that and this is just 13 months after
jim irsay the owner of the team went on
and on about how marlon mack could
become a special player and feels like
he's played his last game for the colts
and meanwhile the colts and the vikings
get together this weekend in
indianapolis 2500 fans authorized to be
present for that game the home opener
for the colts
one of those teams can be owen too
and a lot more people had the colts in
the super bowl than the vikings and uh
it's going to be a stunner either way to
see one of those two teams in the
standings come sunday night at 0-2 chris
yes it is uh and then the colts are
going to be
they they got to be a little sick they
they had no business losing that game
the other day to jacksonville and i
don't want to like sound insensitive to
jacksonville i know they capitalized and
gardner minchu did some good things the
colts didn't punt
you know does people realize that they
were never stopped the whole game
so it was just self-inflicted stupidness
by the indianapolis colts that led the
jaguars to winning that football game
and that's what happens when you let
games slip away like that all of a
sudden you sit there and you go whoa
here we are playing a pretty decent team
and if we don't play we're back our best
or play really good football
it could change our season two weeks
into the year to where all of a sudden
we're already fighting and behind the
eight ball and it's like we're fighting
for your playoff life and we haven't
even got into the swing of football yet
this will be the ultimate litmus test of
what philip rivers has
because a week after aaron rodgers
sliced and diced the vikings defense
what will philip rivers be able to do
will he look like the phillip rivers of
old or will he look like old phillip
rivers last week he looked like old
phillip rivers so a big test for him for
the vikings and somebody is going to be
owen too le'veon bell and the jets are
staring
0-203-0 and 4 in the face again with all
that hope and all that promise and
le'veon bell's out several weeks now
with a hamstring wait wait wait good i
thought there was nothing wrong with his
hamstrings i thought they were
completely fine i thought
that was the tweet he sent out and told
the media after the coach held him out
saying his hamstrings were tight so wait
does hamstrings are hurt now i thought
they were completely fine
it could be a new injury i know it's
quite possible that he was fine then
that there were indeed nothing wrong
with his hamstrings then but there's a
problem with his hamstring now
or he's had stiffness he's had tightness
maybe he's overdone it maybe he didn't
work out as hard as he should have in
the offseason maybe he wasn't as engaged
during the pandemic as he needed to be
to be in the tip-top shape and then
maybe he came in and pushed it a little
bit and he and he you know look this is
a big year for him big i could see the
anxiety overcoming the
concern for your overall health and
well-being as a running back and i i
think i think he's going to get traded
by the trade deadline the tuesday after
week eight and if he's not traded by
then he's not going to be back with the
jets next year i think this is the
beginning of the end for the jets and
le'veon bell i'm with you i don't see
how how it's not really i mean he just
again le'veon bell was amazing before he
shot out football and was certainly one
of the three best running backs in the
game right now where can you honestly
sit there and say he stands they're
paying him like he is one of the five
best running backs in football and i
don't think anybody can sit here
realistically right now and tell me that
le'veon bell is in the top ten
for sure not i mean really i think if we
started to break it down would we
question would go is he top 15 in
football right now i mean that's really
where it goes and i you know again i
just feel bad a little bit for adam gase
here because people are going to blame
adam gates here i'm sure somehow some
way
and i just would like to like remind
everybody that you know some of these
guys that have been issues with the new
york jets are not adam gates guys he had
no
say in bringing them in and dealing with
that but
uh i'm with him mike
he wanted he wanted le'veon bell but not
at that price and a half million per
year and that was a mike mc cagnan that
was like the final nail for mcagne and
his crew that got them fired because
look they got duped and and i i think
gates knew they were getting duped into
this idea that the ravens were going to
pay bell 13.5 million per year they
weren't they weren't there was nobody
else competing with the jets in that
range i i think the 49ers chris were the
next team what around seven or eight for
le'veon bell so uh you you don't want to
have that burden of having that much
money in a running back because there's
an expectation you're going to use him
and you don't build your offense from
the outside in you build it from the
inside out and le'veon bell
is the last piece of the puzzle for a
good offense not the first piece gace
knew it and he's had to deal with it and
i think they're all going to be better
off bell the jets gaze everyone if they
just let him get healthy and trade him
for whatever they can get
yeah i i think so too the thing i'll ask
you
is
do you think a team is going to be
willing to just trade them and maybe i
guess so pay the money see where it goes
you know again just the way it looked
last night i just again look at
pittsburgh and go
it just seems like it's destined to be
that le'veon bell is going to end up in
pittsburgh in some way halfway through
this this year with the way their
running back position looks but i guess
that would be the big question is this
is there going to be a team that's
willing to trade for him because of the
way it's looked
you know last year in hamstring injury
now and then what will be on the hook
for you know six million dollars or six
and a half million dollars for half of
his pay this year i think that'll be the
big question
i think that's the key and then next
year nothing's guaranteed and if you
decide to keep him around you rework his
contract to reflect whatever the cap is
whatever his performance is and this is
the reality of running backs they burn
bright for a relatively short period of
time and just as we are accepting that
they are the best running backs in
football yeah they're already
potentially at the top of the mountain
yeah and starting down the other side
and it's the rare running back it's the
adrian peterson it's the barry sanders
it's the emmett smith it's the christian
mccaffrey potentially that is going to
climb to the top of the mountain and
stay on that plateau for a while before
the inevitable slide begins to happen
and now it's going to be frank gore
having the opportunity to be the
starting running back for the new york
jets and continue to rack up yards as he
tries to pass
uh
eventually emmett smith if he can get
there and just like adrian peterson if
you give frank gore enough years enough
chances enough carries he will pass
emmitt smith the question is finding
someone who will let him do it and now
the jets for the next few weeks are
going to let him do it and gase was
praising gore gore is everything in
gases eyes that bell isn't
and uh
and and it's just
it's it's overdue that these two sides
divorce they've been going through the
motions for too long and i think this
hamstring injury and him being out for a
couple of weeks i personally believe the
goal is i don't know this but i believe
the goal is get him healthy and let's
see who will take him off of our head
yeah that's going to be interesting to
see and uh that would make sense i i i'm
not so sure i don't disagree with you
there i think that how especially if you
missed three four weeks like you're
saying there they might just go okay
yeah it's you know we're in week six
give them one more week you're not
totally ready yet whatever it is and
they almost protect their investment to
make sure they can make a trade happen
and get that off their books i think
that's the way it's going to mike i
agree
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports